Hi, I'm Tom from the Burp Scanner development team. Today I'm going to talk a little bit about
the Crawl Paths view. So this is a brand new feature that we've been thinking about for a
very long time and we're really excited that after several months of development we're finally going
to be able to get it into your hands. So let's just dive straight in and have a look at what it is.
So I've got a crawling audit here of Portswigger's intentionally vulnerable application
in Gin & Juice Shop that I've kicked off and if I open the view details and head over to the Crawl
Paths tab we can see the shiny new view. So what this is showing here is how Burp Suite Scanner's
crawler maps out an application. As it's crawling it's clicking on links, submitting forms, things
like that just like a real user would and then it's viewing web pages again just like a real user would
and we can finally see all of that in product. So on the left here we've got all of the actions
that Burp Suite's crawler has taken. So for example we requested Gin & Juice Shop, we clicked on products
and then we might have clicked on the books category, we've got view details which are all
the different products and then on the right we can see the destination URL so this is taken
straight from Chrome's address bar, we can see the page title and we can also see any HTTP messages
that were sent when we did the action that took us to that page. So for example when we clicked on the
books category it sent off a piece of document traffic to go and load the books category page
but this one the view details tab this is for a particular product that uses a javascript call to
go and load all the product information we can see both of those bits of traffic. So this is similar to
the chrome network tab if you've ever used chrome dev tools in that we're seeing everything that was
needed as an HTTP message to build the page. Now if we've run an audit we can also see all of our issues
these issues being the ones that responded to the h the ones that are relevant to the HTTP messages that
were sent. So again looking at this view details page here we've got our two messages we've got our
document load and our JSON load and we've got an external service interaction issue relating to the JSON.
Now this is really powerful for two reasons. Firstly we finally get to show off what our crawler is
actually doing we've been telling people about this for a very long time and up until now you've just
kind of had to take our word for it so you can now actually see how the crawl is building a tree of the
application so from all of your start URLs to all of the different locations in the application but also
you can finally see your attack surface of the target you're crawling. It also gives you really easy
reproduction steps so if you want to go and have a look at an issue for yourself you can see in the
left here exactly how to get back to the part of the application where that issue is present.
So yeah request Gin and Juice Shop, click products, click view details, it's all there for you.
So we're still actively working on this feature and we've got plenty more planned to come for it
but please do let us know what you think so far.